tom what's your take on this what's your
perspective about who's overseeing this
well look i think the best thing that
happened to us is kamal harris has
nothing to do with this
look this is the same senator who
compared ice to the kkk
she has wrote legislation to reward
illegal behavior those who come to the
country illegally
she supports sanctuary cities she
vilified the border patrol and say they
mistreated migrants during the last
surge
you know so it's obvious that she's the
wrong person to be doing this
if they want if they want someone to
address this crisis what the president
should be doing is talking to the chief
patrol agent
of the united states border patrol who
has dealt this his whole career
let him do what he needs to do let him
actually enforce the laws of this
country
and let him you know change the policies
he needs to get this back border back
secure
tom who do you think is the right person
to sort of
oversee everything at the very big
macro level here we know that customs
and border patrol plays a big part as
does now in this administration
hhs is there a single government
official that you
think is best positioned to manage and
oversee everything and report directly
to president biden
not in this administration look this
administration has shown
they have no they have no intention of
enforcing the law under the trump
administration
we secured the border we arrested those
who enter illegally we detained them
we gave them due process to see a judge
when 90 percent of
90 percent of central americans who
claim fear at the border
never get relief they all get remove
orders and ice removed them
and when that happened when we enforce
the law and show the consequence of
deterrence
the numbers went down on the border but
this administration has made it clear
they've already gutted ice took away 90
percent of their authority isis and
removing these people
and the bourbon instead of having an
enforcement posture borbatro stations
are now welcoming centers
and they're being instructed to release
these people into the u.s with covet
sometimes with covet
as quick as possible detention is not an
option enforcement is no longer an
option
under this administration so you're
there right now with this delegation of
17 republican lawmakers
tell us your impressions that from being
on the ground
so far and tell us the main difference
is you see tom between now
today and the last time you were at this
spot on the border
well under the obama administration we
had another family surge and we stopped
it we stopped it like i said earlier by
enforcing the laws of this country
and now i i started my career in the
border patrol back in 1984 so i spent my
entire career
on immigration enforcement i can tell
you the first night i was here i went
out
in into a place called la jolla and
within 10 minutes i see a group of about
80 family units being detained by the
border patrol
and within the next 10 minutes another
seven come up another eight come up
it was almost like that movie the field
of dreams instead of coming out of the
corner coming out of the brush
turning the cells to the border patrol
within 10 minutes they had 100 families
in custody
then i saw some activity about a half
mile down the dirt road i went down
there
and there's another 100 in custody women
and children and
let me say well the most important thing
i saw now the bright administration said
they got a humane policy the only
humanity i saw
well the only compassion i saw were the
men and women of the border patrol
that actually were hugging these
children i saw a big brawley
morbid choice get on his knees to talk
to a little girl seven-year-old girl
that was crying
and when in a couple of minutes he got
her crack and smile on her face these
men and women the borbacho in a
difficult position
and the other day their
commander-in-chief made a comment they
were watching children die of starvation
on the riverbank and doing nothing about
it
which is disgrace and disrespectful to
any every man and woman that wears that
uniform
that saved over 4 000 migrant lives last
year i saw
compassion i saw compassion for the
border patrol the policies this
administration
has already caused the separation of
nearly 18 000 families
where parents are putting their children
in the arms of criminal cartels to be
smuggled in the united states
31 of women get sexually assaulted
children die
another child died the other day drawn
in the river the policies this
administration
are going to result in open borders and
more immigrant deaths coming across that
border
tom thanks for taking time out of this
tour you're doing with lawmakers we hope
you see some more compassion today along
the southern border we wish you the best
going forward we'd love to get you back
on to hear your thoughts once the trip
is wrapped up thanks tom
thanks for having me